and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bomb
tonight's review x-files I want to
believe
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life there's these
agents called Mulder and Scully to stop
the aliens except that there's not
really any Indians in this one so
they're on to stop doctors performing
illegal operation stick with the aliens
guys and this movie gives us all the
answers to better forget the questions
oh wait I remember one question kill
Mulder and Scully gets it on yes Mulder
and Scully make whoopee gray and that
pavilions a weekend true Aleksey modern
score emic would be three but how about
answering some more in-depth questions
like is et a transvestite there's
something funny about that alien
remember that series walking around in
women's clothing he was liking that a
little too much but instead we get
surgeries oh I'm not going to say what
kind of surgeries they are but let's
just say certainly residencies Sleepy
Hollow will find it useful you're gonna
laugh later so Mulder and Scully are up
to something even factors by using any
pedophile priest who is also a psychic I
swear to God I am not making that up
Marley's the pedophile priests or
psychics imagine one get a pedophile
priest at least a cake and second that
don't imagine it and there's this one
scene where blood starts dripping out of
his eyes though I'm not really sure why
I mean sometimes my eyes bleed raspberry
Janie I was thinking about seeing a
doctor but I only go if it's something
serious so Fox Mulder grows a beard
and he kind of looks like one of the
teachers he's chasing but he shakes it
off and I'm like dude thank God don't
ever do that again I mean I know I have
a beard and really long hair but I can
pull it off dude Jewish but small do
with hunt like me I'm sorry there was
childish so Mulder and Scully stop the
evil doctors and they're like are we
still going to be together whether they
make another movie sure well if they
don't can we still make Whoopie of
course
really play the babies x5 song x-files
you should go see two agents make
whoopee gray this is history boozing
change suggestions I come I got out will
ya come on Jay
will can you in these give me some bread
if we start crying again I want to make
your Trinity sandwich
ah